foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell Join This Hour by my colleague
Christina Ellis best-selling author of
Confessions of a scholarship winner and
we are excited to be taking your calls
about money life student loans
forgiveness is it happening is it not
happening nobody knows Christina it's
been absolute chaos and let me say I am
hot off the flight from San Antonio
where we ended our Live Events season
for the entire year with our Building
Wealth event many thousands showed up
and I love connecting with people it
gave me so much hope for uh for this
generation for the economy for the world
it's amazing what happens when you stop
reading the headlines and you get around
real people who are wanting to improve
their lives regardless of what's
happening in the White House yes the
energy is just electric people are
craving not only that information an
inspiration but to be around other
people who are motivated and excited and
you know changing their own lives yes
and so it's encouraging because the
whole point of this event yes we talk
about how to build wealth despite of
whatever's going on in the economy but
at the heart of it is this idea that we
have control over our financial destiny
we can't control a lot of things in life
but we can control our habits our
behaviors we can set goals we can aim
for those and that is what causes people
to succeed yes and so what's happening
with uh I've just saw headlines floating
around while we were traveling around
the country but you've been keeping up
with the latest and greatest on the
student loan forgiveness debacle tell us
what's happening currently well it's
pretty much feeling like the exact
opposite of control right so many people
are counting on this forgiveness right
now so many people have been promised
forgiveness have been anticipating it
but so far it's not looking so good so
this past week another Court blocked the
student loan forgiveness plan so find
student loan forgiveness is definitely
definitely in limbo right now that's the
second Court to block this so people you
know expecting ten to twenty thousand
dollars in student loan forgiveness
don't exactly know what's going to
happen and there's just a lot of
questions a lot of anxiety in the air
because as of right now that pause is
set to end on December 31st so January
1st payments are due unless they bump
that back again it's due January 1st so
I just think it's such an important
conversation to have right now and a
wake-up call for a lot of people that
you know this may not happen
which is kind of a scary thought because
a lot of people are counting on this
right now a lot of people you know
they're they're not even thinking about
making a student loan payment right now
they're not thinking about that so if
you're in that position right now and
you're really counting on that
forgiveness I would encourage you to
take a moment and think through you know
if this doesn't happen how am I going to
pay these loans off like take this
moment and think how can I be in control
of my finances I don't want to just sit
here waiting and feeling all this
anxiety to see what the you know Biden
Administration is going to do what
Washington's gonna do like take control
of your own finances get on a budget and
start thinking through what will my
financial picture look like if this
forgiveness doesn't happen
yeah well 26 million people right now
are in that limbo as the courts decide
all of this and the email came through
at 3 A.M after voting closed and it was
like Hey we're shutting down
applications for student loan
forgiveness as we uh deal with this and
so it just goes back to what we've
always said regardless of who's in
office never rely on a politician or a
policy to change your life right control
the controllables you can't control
whether or not they're going to do this
forgiveness like that is completely out
of your hands right now so the way to
reduce that anxiety the way to reduce
that concern is to start thinking
through a plan for yourself and what's
going to work for your family
beautifully said well let's get to the
phones this hour it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money Nathaniel kicks us
off in Jacksonville Florida Nathaniel
welcome to the show
science great to be here how are you
guys doing we are doing great how can we
help today
all right so I'm 17 and I'm I'm sitting
on 19 000 in the bank uh I have two jobs
and I make about 12 an hour I'm
wondering where should my money be going
gosh Nathaniel I just want to high-five
you so badly right now you're incredible
how'd you get the 19k just working your
tail off yeah pretty much I mean the
moment I could get to working I started
and you've been working for what two two
three years now
yeah wow and so are you are you living
with family
yep okay what are your future plans are
you looking to go to college you go into
the workforce
uh Yes actually I got a college all
picked out and it's only going to be 10K
for the full four years whoa that's
great how did you do that
um there are you have the smaller state
colleges that we have here in Florida
I just picked one but it's good and
that's what I wanted to do so so what
are you doing right now what's your what
are your two jobs
um one is working as an associate for
Panera and the other is working for
McDonald's nice and what do you want to
do in the future what are you going to
study
I'm going to be studying
computer
development programs and all that cool
so you want to be a software engineer
developer
um maybe a developer actually awesome
that's a great field to go into and uh
as you're finding out you can do that
and not spend 100 Grand on a on a degree
so I love that you have a ten thousand
dollar you know college picked out
that's amazing is that ten thousand
dollars including you know housing and
meals or what what's your plan for
paying for you know everything outside
of the cost of tuition yeah so I still
plan to work while I'm going to college
as well but um it's not that far away
from where I'm living right now
it's like an hour and a half away from
Illinois drive but I could potentially
make a move to be a bit closer if I need
to and get an apartment with some
roommates
uh actually living with family again I'd
be like 30 minutes closer that's cool
okay well what to do with this money you
have nineteen thousand dollars I would
not recommend you invest this money
because right now we need to invest in
Nathaniel and the next few years have a
lot of question marks and unknowns and
so I want to make sure that we get you
through college completely debt free
with a pile of money in the bank and so
the best thing to do with this money is
to put it in a high yield savings
account and and use it to get through
the next few years as you graduate debt
free
and Nathaniel I'm going to challenge you
too is to look into scholarships you
sound like a very on top of it young man
like you've really got a lot going for
you and if you can also just save this
money I love that you're keeping it in a
high yield savings account that you're
going to have that money at the end but
if you can also get somebody else to
help pay for your education and award
you for your accomplishments I mean
that's just gonna be a bonus like icing
on top absolutely and part of this is
going to be your emergency fund you're
driving a car right now right
yep is it pretty reliable
um I have actually like two different
vehicles that I swapped through
um the car that I usually use is are
pretty reliable but then I have another
one that's
and you're paying for the insurance and
everything on both of them
uh not on those so this is where it gets
interesting one of them
you know one of them is my mom's car
that she uses when she's not
um driving down and back in Daytona oh
okay so you're only paying for one of
these cars
yeah all right that makes me feel better
well Nathaniel you were a bright young
man you've got more maturity than I had
at 17 I'll tell you that much and so it
gives me a lot of Hope for you uh get
through college debt free keep this
money safe and sound don't go crazy
investing it you got plenty of time to
do that once you graduate debt free with
an incredible job so proud of you man
more of your calls coming up triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by
Christina Ellis and we're taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five I appreciate all of
you listening into this show I heard
from many at our live events they listen
every single day relentlessly to stay
motivated and inspired on their Journey
so if you like the show here's a
reminder please consider subscribing
leaving a review and sharing it with a
friend and another reminder if you want
to visit us we are just south of
Nashville Tennessee and it's always a
good time in the lobby right now there's
a lemur named Draco who I just got to
meet in the lobby I think the guys are
getting a shot there if you're watching
online and you just never know what
you're going to stumble into and so we
love to meet guests who travel from all
over the country and we love to meet
lemurs named Draco as well I lick my ear
Christina it may be very uncomfortable
it was it was fun watching you squirm
good times so we're gonna go to the
phone lines now Sean joins us across the
pond in London Sean welcome to the show
thank you what's going on
why I am 31 years old and my wife and I
fortunately uh with our we've been
fortunate to stay debt free
um through our Doctorate Degrees and
we're it's time to buy a house and I
have never taken out any debts or
anything in ever in my life and I'm
really hesitant to take this big step
um
and especially with Rising interest
rates
sure so you got your doctorates debt
free
yes sir that's amazing was it through
scholarships did you save how'd you do
it
it's through the U.S military oh right I
guess I should say I I have time
commitment but not Money death yes well
thank you for your service especially as
we celebrated our Veterans Day the other
day there yeah what do you all plan on
doing with their degrees
so uh my wife is a stay-at-home mom
she's uh she's awesome
um and I'm a physician for the military
cool so how long are you going to be in
London for
um just a short time actually looking to
buy a house in in the U.S
what's the timeline for that
uh so looking to buy in the spring at
some point and we'll be in one place
hopefully for at least four years or
longer
okay and so are you moving in the spring
are you moving sooner than that
uh moving in the spring okay would there
be harm in let's say getting a shorter
term lease for six months 12 months
while you guys come back and figure out
where you want to live what
neighborhoods
what what's the Russian going we gotta
buy before we even get back
yeah uh actually we I mean I plan on
being back by the time we are buying so
but to answer your question there's
there's no rush per se is this city that
you're moving to is this a new city are
you moving your family or kind of what
does the situation look like with your
new placement
yeah so it is a new city and and
actually being in the military I'm not
sure where it's going to be
um it's one of three hopefully three
places but uh the concept of buying a
house in this in this inflationary
environment and the current housing uh
boom or bust I'm not sure and Rising
interest rates kind of makes me squirm a
little bit um
well there's also just you know the fact
that you don't have to rush like it's
not that you know you shouldn't buy a
house or you should buy a house but
there's also just a lot of external
factors like the fact that this is a new
city the fact that you're going to move
probably in four years
um the fact that you don't know the
different neighborhoods that you've been
in another country for a while so I
would also just majorly weigh the
personal factors in your decision
because I mean you know we can walk you
through the financial part but I think
there's probably a lot of emotions to
that decision
definitely I think so does it feel like
Hey we're successful we worked hard
we're in our early 30s now we should be
homeowners is that kind of part of it
that's driving this
uh I mean kind of but at the same time I
think part of it is
um
you know when I started looking at rent
at well let me back up I look at a house
payment and I look at the proportion of
money in a mortgage that goes to
interest and that that kind of turns my
my stomach
Source I think it's a rent I'm paying
and one way and I know it's maybe
erroneous but one way to look at it is
to say my rent is 100 interest and uh
you know I I don't want to continue
paying 100 percent interest
uh with no equity and no no forward
momentum yeah well you know it's when
you look at it as just a math equation
or on paper it doesn't make sense when
you look at it as oh I'm buying myself
time I'm being patient I'm transferring
risk to the landlord to the owner that
I'm not having to deal with the
headaches of home ownership and there's
all kinds of costs associated with that
and so I I think you're ready when the
numbers make sense and that means we're
not going to be as concerned about
interest rates because we can always
refinance later down the line if it goes
back down
and when it comes to paying the interest
that house is going to appreciate over
time you are buying an asset that goes
up in value over time and so yes I hate
paying interest and it makes me want to
pay it off faster and that's exactly
what we did and I think that's exactly
what you're going to do too Sean so as
long as you stick to a 15-year fixed
rate mortgage where the payments no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay
that will dictate how much house you
have and instead of it feeling like this
giant scary step you go oh this isn't
that much of our world we can handle
this and more we still have margin to
live our lives to be generous to pay off
our house early so that's the goal of of
living with those within those
parameters yeah and and you know like
George said do the math but also factor
in the closing costs with real estate
too if you're going to be there four
years as you're doing that math remember
that there are closing costs when you
sell a house so one factor that in you
know as you're doing the equation of how
much Equity you're really going to get
over time and what it's going to cost
you and then just also you know take
your time maybe you do take that six
months and kind of feel out the
neighborhood because while it's you know
great to be in the market it's a great
way to build wealth we're seeing a lot
of Articles now with a lot of people
having buyer's remorse where they rushed
into buying a house during the pandemic
they got caught up in this you know
white hot market and this floor green
they felt like the next step in life is
I have to be a homeowner and so they you
know got in line with 60 other people
and they were getting so competitive and
aggressive that they just bought these
houses that they didn't love because
they felt like it was the next right
thing to do so yes I would definitely
weigh both and really feel through both
do the math put it all on paper you know
make sure the numbers make sense and
then also just you know emotionally make
sure it makes sense with your family and
also make sure it makes sense with the
actual house you find that it's
something you're going to be excited
about versus it just being a check mark
on the road to success absolutely Sean
what's your income
uh it is about uh 120 per year awesome
and then do you have money saved
currently for the down payment or is
that next
we do we have uh it's not a lot it's uh
thirty thousand
um
fade for down payment and we we've been
good at maximizing our IRAs and our
um our 401K every year uh up till now
awesome well you know you're in that
kind of uh baby step for land and some
people we call baby step 3B some people
will go hey I'm going to invest up to
the match to be more aggressive with the
down payment uh with your income you
guys are going to be multi-millionaires
at your age being completely debt free
and so regardless of how you do it if
the house is more urgent you could put
more towards that down payment right now
to save up you know 100 100 Grand by the
time you guys move and now we have a
serious down payment
which lowers our monthly payment and so
I want you to feel peace about this and
that's why I recommended hey get back to
the States rent for a while really do
your research work with one of our
endorsed local provider Ramsey trusted
real estate agents uh you can connect
with one at ramsaysolutions.com why
you're there use the mortgage calculator
that we have it's a free tool to help
you figure out how much of this of this
in my world is this going to be and that
gives you peace as well when you go all
right the mortgage is going to be two
grand
with our down payment and we make eight
or ten well that's very reasonable right
and that that becomes from moving from a
big step into a small little walk and
you go wow this house is a blessing
instead of a curse because we didn't
rush into it so we are cheering you on
uh on the journey man call us back when
you got the house and when you when you
pay it off that'll be fun you can do a
debt free scream once you're back stay
outside I love that Christine I was just
talking to one of our real estate elps
endorsed local providers at our Event in
San Antonio and I said how's that how's
it been in real estate because I know
the interest rates are crazy which is
causing less people to buy and he said
well George actually it's been great
because a lot of people regret the house
they bought and so now they're looking
to sell and get to the actual house they
want because they rushed into it and so
a great life lesson there there you have
it don't rush into it do it with peace
do it over time and it's okay if it
doesn't happen tomorrow regardless of
the pressure from your in-laws okay more
of the Ramsay show coming up triple
eight eight two five five two two five 5
is the number to call we'll be right
back
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
folks Thanksgiving is just a week away
and how nice would it be to have some
extra wiggle room in your Black Friday
budget well good news the Ramsey
Christmas Cash giveaway could help take
the stress out of the holiday season
right now you can go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway to enter
for your chance to win one of our weekly
500 prizes or the Big Kahuna the five
thousand dollar grand prize and what's
really cool is you can enter every
single day to increase your chances to
win no purchase necessary but sorry kids
you got to be 18 or older to win so tell
Mom and Dad to go enter at
ramseysolutions.com giveaway while
you're there check out a major sale
happening right now where you can find
Christmas gifts for everyone on your
list some of my favorites right now are
the 2023 Ramsay goal planner that Rachel
Cruz Dr John deloney and myself work
together on to make great or Rachel
Cruz's new wallet in red for the amazing
women in your life I'm gonna get one for
my mom I decided Christina Mom I hope
you're not listening because I just
ruined the Christmas gift gosh I'm not
great at this and for the men we've got
some awesome new Ramsay apparel t-shirts
crewnecks hoodies with some of your
favorite Ramsay sayings on them I'm
hoping for a better than I deserve
sweatshirt myself we'll see if my wife
is listening and she gifts that to me so
for all of your family friends
co-workers we've also got questions for
humans conversation cards that are a
must they're hilarious they'll spark
some great convos and select decks are
on sale right now for only 10 bucks and
if you've used any of our best-selling
books and tools you're fired up to share
what they've done in your life now is a
great time to pay that forward to be
generous to give it to someone else to
start their Journey
so trust me there's something for
everyone on your list you can get it all
done in one place at ramseysolutions.com
you don't have to Doom scroll Pinterest
and Amazon and Etsy hoping to find a
great gift there you go and who doesn't
love a good giveaway that's always so
exciting you know you just want to enter
now this is different than Powerball you
know because number one it cost me
nothing and there's a much higher chance
of me winning yeah that's how I feel
about our giveaway now you won't win two
billion dollars but hey any giveaway is
exciting I once won a giant Yoda doll
after entering at a blockbuster give a
Blockbuster Video giveaway every single
day and I finally won it what happened
to the Yoda I sold it on eBay for 400
bucks oh my goodness that is next level
I'm very impressed with you Christina
thanks George way to hack the system all
right I showed Blockbuster you showed
them now they're bankrupt thanks to you
it's your fault me and my yoda doll all
right open phones this hour at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Greg joins us in Arlington in Texas Greg
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you for taking my call
my wife is retiring due to health
matters December the 15th and she's got
in her 401K she's got fifty thousand
dollars
uh our house is paid for but everybody
has a different opinion because we may
have to turn to that fifty thousand
dollars for an emergency or we would
want to draw the interest that it would
make which I understand is not a lot of
money to a lot of people that'd be a ton
to us uh uh once a year draw that
interest out and some people are saying
I'll just put it in a CD and some are
saying an IRA and an IRA Roth and God it
is so confusing that I that I don't know
what to do well you've got a lot of
voices coming at you at once don't you
Greg well you you read you know you can
read on uh one page on the internet you
know don't eat eggs and on the next page
it'll say yeah
yeah that's so true that's so true and
that's what I run into when I read or
try to obtain knowledge so you know I'm
sitting here watching YouTube and there
was a Dave Ramsey and I thought why
can't it hurt all you can do is give me
some decent advice and so I thought I'd
call in because the 50 is it's important
to us oh absolutely like I said we put
all our money into the house and it's
paid for
and and so I don't know I love it do you
have any other debt
I have you know about like three
thousand dollars on a credit card on
credit cards that I could pay off it's
easy enough so you're the man you both
still have income
yeah well well I have my Social Security
uh and uh she'll get her social security
so the our standard of living are the
amount of money that we get it per month
will drop greatly
what will that be once she retires what
will your monthly income be now we're
going to be around 25
000 a year wow and Greg are you still
working or are you fully retired
no I you know I I do a lot of jobs here
and there but I was a Salesman and
salesmen are not the greatest people in
the world they're doing on jobs and so
it that's kind of been hard but where I
can find things to do I do them uh I've
got some money in the stock market and I
try to stay on top a bit but it's not
much you know it's it's like five
thousand dollars and in single stocks
where are you investing currently
uh it's in single stocks just just
things that I look at and I think well
you know eventually cheap stocks though
they're they're
I think the most expensive one sheer
stock that I would have would probably
be uh
seven eight dollars yeah per share you
know and you got a car payment as well
yeah I have a car payment that's 398.
what's left on the line
okay
go ahead I'm sorry well I'm just looking
at the numbers here going man if you
guys could get rid of this debt it would
give you a nice cushion of margin to
have if you're going to be living off of
Social Security
and so I'd want you to get rid of the
Jeep get I'd if you could I'd pay that
stuff off ASAP I don't know if it's
worth selling at this point because you
need to go out and buy another vehicle
but on the financial side when you're
looking at your Investments I want you
to get out of the single stock game
that's going to be a volatile game it's
not worth your time it's not worth your
money
and as far as that 401k uh I don't want
you touching it unless you have to and I
don't want you using it as an emergency
fund because that's what your emergency
fund is for so do you guys have money
outside of retirement just in the bank
no we got we put everything into the
house which now I'm finding out is not
such a great idea for us I don't know I
mean what what does it paid for our
house do for us financially well it gets
rid of your largest fixed expense which
is your mortgage payment so that's a
great sign but true I would not have
told you to drain your your bank account
for it we want you to have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
with no debt and then pay off the house
and so you did some good things in this
picture but if I'm in your shoes I'm
going to stop listening to the internet
and random voices and I'm going to
connect with a Ramsay smartvester Pro
these are Financial investing Pros that
we vet that do things the Ramsey Way
that want to help you want to teach you
and so go connect with one of those go
to the website ramseysolutions.com click
on Ramsay recommends and you can get
connected with one in your area and then
tune out the other voices you know tune
out all the different people's opinions
be careful who you listen to like get
somebody who's a real Pro and we
appreciate you calling in today and
Trust us to give you advice but you know
sit down with a smart investor you know
and they'll really be able to guide you
through all the different aspects of
your finances they can kind of talk you
through you know developing that
emergency fund and their 401k and how to
make sure you can afford everything
moving forward I don't want you to
describe
I'm just that conversation if you if you
go buy another car you're immediately
starting that interest again well we're
not going to tell you to buy one
majority of the interest on this
particular one I mean that's how they
all car payments are set up I was a I
used to run a car dealership well we we
believe that you can live without a car
payment and that means buying a used car
with cash no interest no payments
and so if you're not doing a lot of
driving 400 on what my real question is
is what should I do with the 401K I know
leave it where it is once you want to
leave it somewhere where it's going to
make the maximum amount of money sure
because where it's sitting now it's
making like two and a half percent well
you can do better than that in a
high-yield savings account Craig so
here's what I'm gonna tell you to do I
my recommendation would be once she
retires do a direct rollover to an IRA
and that smartvestor Pro that you
connect with can help you through that
process that's going to be the safest
bet with no tax burden and that will
allow it to continue to grow with some
good mutual funds so wishing you guys
the best in retirement and getting
through all this mess I believe you
don't have to scrape by in retirement
you guys can enjoy it if we start doing
the right things right now thanks for
the call Greg this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money up next we head to
St Louis Lindsay is on the line there
welcome to the show Lindsay
hi there I'm excited to talk to you guys
we are excited to talk to you how can we
help today
awesome well at the beginning of the
year I'm looking to make a career change
and I actually read Christina's book and
I'm looking to work my way through hair
school
um so I don't qualify for FAFSA because
of how much money I make and how much
money I have but I'd like to get as many
scholarships as possible um so I don't
have to pay it out of pocket and so I
just wanted to see if you guys had any
advice for getting scholarships for a
trade school versus like a normal
four-year degree and if it's like the
same I couldn't I didn't find as many
scholarships so I don't know if it's I'm
just not looking in the right places or
if it's
um just a little different well I love
that you're motivated to go debt free
that just makes me so excited and that
you've done the research you've done the
homework I'm just like get it girl
that's awesome
but okay so starting with scholarships I
mean there are some scholarships that
are specifically for trade school but a
lot of times just the regular
scholarships that you find also qualify
for trade school so I'd encourage you to
not just limit yourself to trade school
scholarships but look for a broad range
of scholarships and in that you know
check the guidelines so that's a thing
that a lot of people don't do until
they've applied for a scholarship and
they've spent all the time doing it and
then they realize perhaps they didn't
qualify or there was some certain little
guideline they didn't check so you know
there are millions of scholarships out
there and you can't apply for all of
them so take the time on the front end
to you know read the little fine print
and make sure you know that it qualifies
for a trade school that you know it's
not just limited to four years because a
lot of them you know are open to either
and if you can't find that info just
give them a call or email I think a lot
of people feel like scholarship programs
are these like far out there things and
that there's not like real people behind
them
um but a lot of times it's you know
foundations as people who are really
passionate about education and giving
away money so I mean just picking up the
phone and asking for clarification is
totally okay
okay awesome can you ask a follow-up
question yeah of course
okay so this is kind of like an
entrepreneurial route like um going to
hair school and I'm wanting to you know
replace my income next year even while
in hair school and so but also my
husband is looking to leave his job so
I'm wondering like we're following we're
trying to follow the baby steps so we
have a little bit more in our emergency
fund than normal and so
um and we just got married so I'm trying
to figure out like how much should we
set aside being that we both are looking
to leave our jobs in in the near future
so is he going back to school or is he
just trying to find a different job
you know he does video and photography
full-time
um at a company and he's looking to do
that on his own
okay so he's going to be an entrepreneur
so I definitely would say if that's the
case go you know we recommend a three to
six month emergency fund go to the upper
end of that the six months you know
especially if he's going to be an
entrepreneur you're going to be in
school
um you know go for the upper end of that
and then also with you going to school
you know one of the biggest priorities
right now is for you to go debt free so
any extra cash that you have I would set
aside you know for an education fund you
know of course we want you to win
scholarships I hope that you get it
fully funded with scholarships but if
you do need to cash flow some of that
you know I would take you know the money
that's over and above that emergency
fund and really set that aside for your
education
okay how much is hair school gonna cost
um so it's about twenty three thousand
okay and do you have the money now are
you just hoping to cash flow it with
scholarships along the way
I do have the money but obviously I
don't want to spend it if I don't have
to we're also trying to pay off our
house early so I'd like to spend that on
the house rather than on the school
um
well for sure the school is going to be
the priority to get through debt free
and if it slows down the house process
I'm okay with that because I don't want
you to go backwards in this process and
if he's able to continue working while
getting his you know his side uh hustle
off the ground starting his own business
I would rather that than have a gap in
income
and so regardless of what happens there
should be no Gap in income even if it's
you guys are hustling you're doing Uber
you're doing everything it takes to keep
income coming in the door because that's
a recipe for disaster for both of you to
just stop working and hope to get
through life for sure
for sure that's awesome I have a pump
for you guys yeah I would also just
encourage you to spend a little time
researching if there's any programs that
specifically help with trade school in
your state so I know here in Tennessee
we have this program called Tennessee
reconnect which it helps you know adults
go back to school and get trade
certificates so I would encourage you to
see if there's anything like that in
your state because you know scholarships
are great but if there's some program
that's kind of a direct route you know
that could be a much quicker and easier
process
yeah I'll definitely look into that
thank you absolutely we're excited
pretty much for the call Lindsay very
cool and thank you for reading
Christina's book how awesome is that I
love that all right let's move on to
Brittany in Dallas Texas Brittany
welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
what's going on
so my question is in regards to an HSA
medical account insurance okay um so I
currently have a trip it's open
enrollment for my company right now and
I currently have a good traditional
insurance is that PPO
um
I don't know what it is it's either a
PPL or HMO well it doesn't say okay
there were there's usually either a high
deductible health care plan or a PPO
which is preferred provider organization
does any of those ring a bell yes okay
thank you
and uh
looking at this big chart and
HSA
essays of the DraStic saving on the
bi-weekly contributions but obviously
the deductible is higher the reason I'm
asking about this now is because my
husband and I we do know that ideally we
want to start trying for kids at some
point next year so I don't know if now
would be a good time to switch from a
good traditional Insurance to something
with a higher deductible higher maximum
out of pocket that sort of thing well
the nice thing with the high deductible
health care plan is once you hit that
max out of pocket it should be covered
at 100 percent and so if you can find
one like my wife just we just went
through this process here at Ramsay and
there was an option that was a slightly
lower max out of pocket and then it
covered 100 and the trade-off is you pay
a slightly higher premium and so that
might be a good option for you guys and
I always recommend to have that amount
in your emergency fund depending on
where you guys are at in the baby step
so are you trying to pay off debt right
now
no we're completely done we're on four
five six oh I love it then let's max out
that HSA and make sure we have enough to
cover the max out of pocket because then
you know hey we're covered regardless of
what happens we're not going to be on
the hook for some crazy medical bill
okay so I'm looking at the chart now and
it's saying after I hit my deductible
the non-prevelative services I would pay
20 up until the max out of pocket so if
that's still what you're talking about
with the 100 coverage after after the
max out of pocket
okay what you would recommend
transitioning yeah I mean if you if
everyone's relatively healthy here and
uh it's a great option many many people
here at Ramsey do it uh my wife and I
included have the high ductable so
that's how you get the HSA account is
through a high deductible health care
plan and then with that you get the HSA
which is the health savings account and
that allows you to I love it because
it's triple tax benefits you put the
money in completely tax-free from your
gross income it grows tax-free you can
invest it Beyond a certain threshold and
you can withdraw it tax-free for
qualified medical expenses so it's an
incredible incredible option A lot of it
a lot of them have employer matches does
yours
yes 1500. oh that's incredible lovely so
I mean obviously I want you to read the
fine print do what makes sense for your
family but if I'm in your shoes just
hearing what I heard it makes a lot of
sense to move over to that high
deductible health care plan
okay what is the max out of pocket on it
uh for the employee plus one is seven
thousand okay oh that's similar to ours
and so if you've got that in the
emergency fund you can max out the HSA
as well to have it uh come out of there
that's a great option and so I would
recommend going that route you can also
talk to there's usually someone
connected to your health care plan that
you can reach out to we actually just
met with one that was here at Ramsay
from Xander insurance that helped us go
oh here's what this means here's what
makes sense based on what you're telling
me so I would reach out to your HR team
as well and see if they can get you in
touch with someone who can help walk you
through the options
okay yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense
awesome well thank you so much for the
call Brittany awesome and hey folks it's
open enrollment season like help your HR
people out they're all frantic right now
trying to make sure everyone does what
they need to do so hit those deadlines
make it easy on them and ask questions
make sure you do your due diligence
because this is big decisions and
bankruptcy uh number one leading cause
of bankruptcy is medical bills so you
gotta get health care coverage right
what a fun note to end the hour on
Christina talking about hsas and ppos we
love it you truly do love hsas I really
do I'm such a nerd that puts this hour
of the Ramsay show in the books we will
be back with you before you know
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money I'm George Campbell host of the
fine print the entree leadership podcast
and co-host of smart money happy hour
joined by Christina Ellis and we are
taking your calls at the number eight
eight two five five two two five we're
kicking it off with Jan in Chicago Jan
how is it going over there
well
um I have some school debt and some
credit card debt and just looking for
some advice on how to restructure our
lives so we can get out of this debt wow
well the fact that you're willing to
talk like that means you guys are ready
for a change
absolutely sounds like you've had your
I've had it moment
yeah so you definitely had it
um I came to a realization
um with the school that I'm actually
going to be exponent to leave school and
look for a job just so that we can get
out of that how far are you in your
schooling
um so I have been about a year uh close
to a year and a half into schooling
um I was going to go to law school and
then realize I don't think I want to
practice and so it doesn't really make
sense for me to continue with the degree
um so that cost the pretty penny of
course so this is your year and a half
into law school
of course yeah
so how much student loan debt and how
much credit card debt
um so total we have about 108 000 in
student loan debt and then credit card
debt we have about six thousand dollars
okay and when you say we is that your
your spouse me and my spouse correct
okay
and what's your income household
right now um we just have one income and
it's about 115 000.
and then you're you're gonna leave
school soon what are you gonna do after
that
administrative work
um I'm just trying to find something
because I'm realizing that this debt has
turned into kind of a snowball and
um we're definitely not looking to to
take on more debt and so
um what is your undergrad what's your
undergrad degree in
um political science
okay
and do you do you feel like you have you
want to stay completely away from law in
any capacity right now or are you still
kind of open to maybe paralegal work or
something in the field
I'm open to work in the field just you
know because I don't really have too
much of a choice at this point
um but it would be nice to kind of pivot
if that's possible but I mean I've
worked in the field for for some time I
was a legal assistant uh prior to school
so I could always go back to that I just
I don't want you to wait until you're
dead for you to do something you love
and so that's what we're trying to get
you plugged into while you become debt
free and if you can do that and get paid
well and actually enjoy doing it it's
going to make this whole experience a
whole lot better well you'll probably
make more money doing something that
you're passionate about like I think
right now it feels really overwhelming
and you feel kind of you know a lot of
of guilt around leaving this degree and
you know maybe some shame but you still
have a lot of value and I it just
because you're leaving law school does
not mean you can't have a successful
career doing something completely
different and get paid really well doing
it
yeah that's actually pretty encouraging
because I was thinking that I kind of
just had to take anything to to help us
get out of this debt because it's it's a
lot and school loans are pretty tough
yeah it's it's overwhelming right now it
feels like you are staring at a mountain
and it's easy to just want to start
running as fast as possible which we do
want you to run as fast as possible and
be gazelle intense but we want you to do
it with the best strategy with a career
that you love that you're going to be
one of you you're going to want to be
fired up to get up every morning and go
to work and take on an overtime job and
you know anytime the boss says we need
somebody to work late tonight that
you're going to go hey me hey me you
know and get a bonus for doing that like
the more you're feeling passionate about
what you're doing the more you're going
to show up you know and want to go above
and beyond which often translates into
more income
yeah and that's a really good point that
you make
um there's nothing worse than being
miserable at a job and then also trying
to pay off debt
um and
another issue too is like we have really
high rent because we've lived here in
the city
um and so it's close to 3 500 a month so
when I'm thinking about restructuring
we're wondering if it would be better to
just like move to the suburbs or
um that's that's a tough one there too
it makes it harder for us to pay down
debt
well is he is he working in the city
yes okay so it would be a little bit
more of a commute so there's a trade-off
there we don't want him driving two
hours each way to work so is there a
trade-off where you could lower your
rent to two thousand dollars a month
live a little further outside of the
city and still have them have a
reasonable commute
yes I think that would be possible
that's something that we're looking into
and I think that would probably make the
most sense for us
um because yeah like what we're
obviously exceeding our income in bed
what size like what size apartment are
you renting right now
right now we're in a two bedroom
I mean I know it would be a little bit
of a squeeze there's also just weighing
that you know do you want to live
further out or do you want to go down to
a one bedroom or maybe even a studio for
a season like if living close to the
city is a big priority there's also kind
of going a little bit smaller do you
guys have kids
um right now we don't and we're thinking
about it but yeah okay yeah I think
either way you go whether you live a
little bit further you know get a little
bit of a smaller spot or maybe even rent
out the other room
um getting that 35 that's going to be
compromise either way so it's you
deciding on is he on board is he on fire
like you are to make some changes
um absolutely
um I'm the one that's kind of driving it
and he's on board with it so awesome hey
for a lot of people that's half the
battle you're just getting their spouse
on board so that's great well I wanna I
wanna leave you with some resources Jan
so that you feel equipped and one of
those is Ken Coleman our Ramsay
personality and colleague he's got an
assessment called the get clear career
assessment because I think right now
you're kind of at this Crossroads you've
lost a little bit of hope that your
dreams are shattered and we want to tell
you that there is hope for you that you
can do work that you love and this
assessment is going to take you about 15
or 20 minutes and it's going to spit out
some amazing results that very clearly
show you where your passions your
talents your mission lie and give you
career options of things you can look
into
that sounds great and I also want to get
you a copy of paycheck to purpose that's
Ken's book and it's going to help you
you know go from you know just looking
for a job that's going to pay off these
student loans to finding a job that
gives you purpose that you're excited
about like we talked about earlier that
gets you fired up so it's kind of The
Best of Both Worlds absolutely and let's
pile on Financial Peace University have
you guys been through that as a couple
we have not been through it as a couple
oh you're gonna love it yeah you're
gonna love that so it's nine lessons I
want you to watch all of them together
you can also join a local class that is
the best way to do it because getting
around other people who are on the same
Journey as you there's nothing like it
uh with that we're going to throw in
every dollar premium to help you guys
get a plan for your money every single
month make decisions and uh you're the
boss of the budget until you make the
budget and the budget becomes the boss
of you and that is going to give you
such freedom because now it's not a
fight it's no no we decided we're gonna
spend this much on food and that's why
we're not eating out and so you guys got
this you have a great income it's going
to go up you're going to come back into
a debt free scream and I cannot wait for
that day so hang on the line Austin's
gonna pick up and give you from paycheck
to purpose to get clear career
assessment Financial based University
and every dollar premium Austin you've
got some work to do man good luck with
that but we love doing it congrats we
are cheering you guys on this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
mine is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you are listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour and we're taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five our question of the
day comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself about their 100 satisfaction
guarantee it means even if you miss
measure or pick the wrong color they
will remake your blinds for free you get
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you will
save even more use the promo code Ramsay
to get the best deal today's question
comes from Bill in Arkansas I bank with
truest bank and they offer a Delta
SkyMiles reward debit card it has a 99
or less depending on spending annual fee
but you get one mile for every two
dollars spent on all purchases except
ATM withdrawals the rewards do not
expire my wife's family lives a few
States over and we are currently
inheriting a family business so we do
travel quite a bit is this worth it in
your opinion
oh boy I'm I'm fired up about this one
Christina
no bill it is not worth it even though
it's a debit card I am not paying to
have a debit card and you just laid out
here's here's the deal you pay 99 but
here's the blessing Christina you get
one mile for every two dollars spent
here's the thing yeah let's when it
comes to miles there is no indication of
what one mile even means and so Bill's
in Arkansas and so I did a little pre
pre-show math here to go from Little
Rock to Arkansas A Little Rock to
Nashville round trip in December
is 31 000 points
so if you're doing the math at home one
mile for every two dollars spent that
means 30 000 miles is sixty thousand
dollars worth of spending for one person
to go round trip from Little Rock to
Nashville and back ouch
so you're going to pay a hundred dollars
for the annual fee then spend sixty
thousand dollars of your net income on
God knows what to go from Little Rock to
Nashville and back that same flight if
you just paid for it on the same airline
Delta would cost 282 dollars wow enjoy
your miles bill
so no never let rewards Drive decisions
right well and like what does that do to
the psyche to make you one want to make
sure you spent enough to make your 99
dollar fee worth it but then thinking
man I really want to get enough points
to get this flight so sixty thousand
dollars is the bar I have to reach I
feel like that encourages spending oh
absolutely and then you feel like you
won we go hey we got a free flight so
Christina I don't understand what the
issue is yeah but you spent sixty
thousand dollars to get it oh and so
your math is broken here uh so no never
do that and it's one of the reasons
Christina we launched our very own debit
card called gazelle uh the other day and
one of the reasons is we're sick of
banks screwing people over and so we
don't fee you to death there's no annual
fee there's no we don't even do
overdraft because we're like we don't
want you to spend money you don't have
it will just decline
and so it's a great way to spend and
save the Ramsay way if you want to check
that out but Bill I'm not falling for
this uh Sky Miles rewards debit card man
just do a budget save up for your
vacations pay for the flights do your I
like to use Google flights and
Skyscanner and all kinds of online tools
to just find the best deal on a flight
instead of being beholden to one Airline
right that's what I was going to say is
this is just through Delta like if you
look around at some of the cheaper
Airlines there's a good chance you could
find a flight for a hundred bucks
anyways you know Little Rock to
Nashville is not Far We've driven that
several times so one you could drive if
you really want to go but at the same
time like just shop around we both love
travel we both love travel deals we're
kind of obsessed with Skyscanner and
finding the best flight and it's like
you can do this in a much smarter way
yes so uh don't fall for this folks if
you're seeing these rewards and you see
well it's a debit card so that's helpful
but oh wait there's an annual fee and so
now I have to spend enough to at least
cover the annual fee which is going to
cause me to spend enough to cover the
annual fee and so it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy here that will cause you to be
broke so Bill I hope you say no to this
debit card and just stick to a no fee
debit card and don't spend because of
the rewards thanks for the question
though it's a good it's a good
discussion it's a good discussion
because it's very tempting like when you
see that and you see miles and you see
the potential of a free flight like
that's exciting and it can kind of get
you stirred up to where you don't really
want to look at the math you're just
excited to go somewhere excited to you
know get on an airplane that seems very
cool and it's like wait a minute when
you break this down it's not really as
cool as this it's never worth it and
Christina we did an entire episode on
the fine print about this very topic
it's about credit card rewards but now
that debit cards are starting to try to
compete in this weird space we have to
watch out for this as well so you can go
listen to it it's episode two of the
fine print podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts called the true cost of
credit card rewards and I talked to an
ex-employee of Capital One whoa who dish
is and she explains how they do tens of
thousands of experiments every year on
consumers to get them to spend more and
instead of cash back they went hey what
if we did like points and Miles because
that's confusing and they could you
could be a hundred thousand points and
you feel like you're winning but really
uh you're a loser so I'll fall for this
don't fall you're just a rat in the Maze
and you get to the cheese and you think
you won Until you realize oh my gosh I'm
in a maze I'm in a tiny prison
my gosh that's so sad I know studying us
like rats we made Christina sad thanks
credit card companies all right let's go
to the phones this hour uh to Kansas
City we go Jackie joins us there Jackie
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi there thanks for taking my call
absolutely what's going on
okay so my husband is going to retire
from the Marine Corps in two and a half
years and we have a small acreage that
we bought it's back in Iowa and we hope
to build a home on that in roughly two
and a half years
um we have some money saved up but we're
butting heads and so you guys are going
to settle this floor oh this is fun
don't put me in between a marine I will
not win
so we're discussing
taking a pause from saving and putting
money into our Roth account and our
children's education account so we can
have less of a mortgage on our home and
then you know once the home is built
that's not where the finances end
um well we're going to start like a
little bit of a hobby farm for our two
younger kids
and we homeschool and so that is going
to be you know our new life and our new
education for our kids as they're
growing up
um so that's the question do we kind of
put a hold on saving and getting that
money when we're older because we need
more money now
do you do you need more money as in like
you need more money for the down payment
or do you already have a down payment
s we have a doubt yeah we have money
saved up okay how much do you have saved
up
we have 350 000 in our savings account
just a liquid cash
yeah oh my gosh you guys are amazing get
it and we have a hundred and ten
thousand dollars in the stock market
okay what is that in is it in mutual
funds or single stocks or what I think
it's I think it's mutual funds I think
it's pretty safe
um but that's non-retirement
yeah that's non-retirement okay and we
have yeah we've got and then we have
money in our Roth retirements as well
and about how much do you anticipate the
home build is going to cost
um with the new higher prices I mean we
were
we've been saving for 20 years and we've
always had it in our mind about five
hundred thousand dollars
um but that's kind of creeping up maybe
it'll go down we're not sure and I know
interest rates are going up so I mean
our goal was just to build a house well
it sounds like you're gonna be able to
pay cash for it
um yeah we're just we're just wanting to
save a little bit more yes and get to
that point
um well that's kind of the debate right
like do we pause all of our investing in
order to stockpile the cash to cover the
home build and well or do we I mean if
you guys had it took even took on a
mortgage you're talking about like a
forty thousand dollar loan
well it might be upwards you know with
the with the Home Building cost
s 100 700
um but then the cost don't end after
that because we have it's a it's a it's
a just a cornfield right now
um and so we're wanting to build that up
and so we need equipment we need
tractors we and this is all just for the
kids to have a hobby
well it's like our passion is what we
want to do with our lives after the
Marine Corps take your time with that
cash flow it as you go
um you can pause investing for a short
while but I wouldn't do it for very long
not more than six months as you save up
with that much saved up I'm still doing
four and five steps four and five I'm
still investing for retirement and
saving for my kids college at the same
time because you guys have a lot saved
up you're beyond you know what you need
and if it takes longer for the home
build by six months because of that
that's okay you will live to tell the
tail you can rent for a little while but
I want this thing to be a blessing and
not a curse so take your time move
slowly and you'll get to that dream
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show it's a show
about you and your life and your money
and you can call us at triple eight
eight two five five two two five some
say the advice is worth what you pay for
it I'm George Campbell joined by
Christina Ellis this hour and uh
Christina there's a clip I want to play
from a 2018 shareholder meeting with uh
our friends I wish they were my friends
Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger very
very wealthy old men and uh it's talking
about cryptocurrency and I'll tell you
why I played it afterwards but let's get
your take on this clip from the 2018
shareholder meeting
they're nothing being produced in the
way of value from the asset that
you also have the problem that it draws
in a lot of charlatans and that sort of
a thing who are trying to create various
sorts of exchanges or whatever it may be
it you know it's something where where
people who were of less than Stellar
character see an opportunity to clip
people who were trying to get rich
because their neighbors getting rich
buying this stuff and neither one of
them understands
it will come to a bad ending Charlie
well I like crypto currencies a lot less
than you do
and so to me it's just dementia and I
think the people were professional
traders that go into trading
cryptocurrencies it it's
it's just disgusting it's like somebody
else is trading turds and you decide I
can't be left out
gosh I love this so much I feel like you
would fit in well on that stage talking
about your disdain and I've always
thought I was an old soul and I'm like
these are the guys I want to hang out
with these are my people Warren and
Charlie need a podcast okay so let me
recap in case you didn't hear what they
said Warren Buffett said that
cryptocurrency draws in a lot of
charlatans who are trying to create
various sorts of exchanges whatever it
may be it's something where people who
are of less than Stellar characters see
an opportunity to clip people who are
trying to get rich because their
neighbors getting rich buying the stuff
that neither one of them understands it
will come to a bad ending his friend
Charlie Vice chairman of Berkshire
Hathaway which is Warren's uh investment
firm holding company said crypto is like
somebody else trading turds and you
decide I can't be left out
and that is the definition of fomo and
what this kind of get rich quick crypto
greed culture has turned into and
there's a reason I played this clip from
four years ago who knew it was
foreshadowing Christina because the news
came out this week
that one of the largest cryptocurrency
exchanges FTX
just filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy and
the collapse is being compared to Enron
and Bernie Madoff and it is a wild wild
story
so the company's founder Sam bankman
freed faces allegations that he secretly
transferred 10 billion dollars from FTX
to Alameda research which is his hedge
fund that also filed for bankruptcy and
there's he's facing a criminal probe in
the Bahamas for this and it's not going
to end well and he went from a 16
billion dollar net worth to a zero
dollar net worth because of this
collapse and all of the users that have
accounts may never see the money again
oh their accounts went down to zero and
now there's going where where to happen
here and uh a lot of people have
compared this to Lehman uh I would
compare to Imran one said
and this is crazy just a crazy story and
it really goes back to what those old
guys were talking about which are some
of the wealthiest smartest guys in the
financial World which is that there's so
much fraud and delusion in the
cryptocurrency world and it's a sad
thing to see I think so many people just
want it to work because they want that
get rich quick feeling they want to have
success instantly it's been interesting
talking to people who you know are
obsessed with crypto being somebody in
the money space you know it's like I
want to tell me more tell me more I want
to understand why you're so passionate
about this they're so much nicer than I
am Christina Well it's hard because like
a lot of them don't have answers for how
it works it's like wait how is your
money safe you don't understand the
blockchain Christina it's like this is
the future man you're so out of touch
oh my gosh and and here we are
at its peak it was the third largest
crypto exchange and it's just gone to
put and millions of dollars worth of
assets just unaccounted for yeah that's
scary very scary and so I love I'm a big
fan of Warren Buffett so much wisdom uh
one of the wealthiest people on planet
Earth 97 billion dollar net worth
and I just wanted to share some of the
ways that he lives that I think we can
all take away and live a little bit
smarter a little less uh frivolous if
you will so here's an article that
covers some of that one uh buy a modest
home he says he still lives in the same
home in Omaha Nebraska that he had since
the 50s and the dude has as much I mean
he could buy islands for days right I
love this one that says don't be afraid
to use coupons in front of friends my
man and he talks about or I guess Bill
Gates talks about a story where they
were at a McDonald's in Hong Kong and
Buffett offered to pay and he dug into
his pocket and pulled out coupons to pay
for Bill Gates meal I love that so much
that's that's amazing another one look
for sales and Deals this one I'm
personally passionate about I'm very I
call myself bougie Frugal I like the
Finer Things in life but I'm still going
to get a deal on it and I'm gonna be
very intentional
um and this is something he's very
passionate about is doing the research
can I get a better deal on this
negotiate all that stuff that's good I
like that he also says don't gamble that
gambling is a tax on ignorance I think
that's really important especially now
with all the online gambling and it's
like gambling is getting so mainstream
it's you watch a football game and
there's all these different commercials
encouraging you to gamble well and you
can do sports betting and you can bet on
the tiniest little pieces of the game
yeah and you think well I'm just having
some fun and all of a sudden you're like
I just blew 500 bucks this month yeah or
I'm hooked on it and I feel like I can't
stop I mean it's becoming an addiction
an actual legitimate addiction or you
think I'm gonna be the next Powerball
winner and win two billion dollars right
uh there's there's a much higher chance
you get struck by lightning a thousand
times in the same spot than winning that
Powerball uh and we've we've called the
lottery attacks on the poor and very
similar to what Buffett says here yeah
and then he also says forget fancy food
which I feel like we can all get on
board with that you know he said he he
literally could afford Lobster you know
for every single meal but he's really
cautious with what he eats and is
mindful of that so I mean for all all
y'all on beans and rice you know maybe
you maybe you stick with that a lot
you're just living like Warren Buffett
that's all there you go yeah well Dave's
always said you know you eat enough
Lobster it tastes like soap eventually
and so even the Finer Things in life you
know at some point it's it loses its its
specialness if you will another one
don't upgrade possessions unless you
have to Buffett famously used the Nokia
flip phone for years although he's moved
on to an iPhone my man you know he would
he has standards Christine he's like I'm
not getting an Android all right let's
enjoy life oh that's a good one
that's awesome I like that he also said
pick inexpensive hobbies his favorite
hobby is playing bridge and that if he
ever went to jail he would hope that his
friends in jail would play with uh play
bridge with him please don't go to jail
Warren we need you you're a Voice of
Truth in a world gone mad uh the last
one here that I think is fun is forget
fancy clothing yes you know just go the
Steve Jobs route just wear a turtleneck
every day you think I should do that
Christina I'm on board with that I like
simplifying I get I'd get too
claustrophobic because too much fabric
for me guys let's stop it at the neck
you don't get any more than that
oh good stuff there a lot of Timeless
wisdom though in a lot of what they said
and I've I've said on the show now for
months and months if you follow the
trends you will fall for the traps and
anytime something comes on the horizon
that everyone gets a little you know
starry-eyed about I go oh I'm gonna step
back
is this does this have a proven track
record what's behind this thing and
Warren Buffett said he wouldn't buy all
the crypto in the world for 25 all the
Bitcoin because it produces nothing and
you can see what happens when nothing is
produced it's a house of cards and the
whole thing can just collapse and so
only invest in things with a long-term
track record even when it's boring and
that's what we found in a millionaire
study is that it's 401ks and paid for
real estate and IRAs and mutual funds
that's what causes long-term wealth and
what causes you to keep it yeah and it
may not look as fun and flashy in the
moment you may not you know have instant
success but it's what is going to stand
the test of time yeah and I've I've made
the analogy that it's like popcorn in
the microwave and you've been there
Christina when it goes one second too
long in the microwave and it's burnt
like how did the it was in there one
second too long I had 16 billion in the
bank the other day and now it's zero
that's exactly it and you're gonna get
burnt Christina if you live the
microwave lifestyle and so I need
everyone listening to be a crock pot and
a world full of microwaves it tastes
better you don't have to worry about it
no one's freaking out about what's on
the crock pot it's gonna be fine don't
be fine and so be patient the Bible says
Proverbs 13 11 wealth gained hastily
will dwindle but whoever gathers little
by little will increase it so good
Timeless wisdom right there more of the
Ramsay show coming your way
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you know that feeling you get when you
finally remember to leave your keys by
the front door so the next morning when
you're running late they're right where
they're supposed to be yeah you want to
go and high five your past self for
being so smart and planning ahead well
here is one of those opportunities we
are heading into the holiday season
where our brains are focused on buying
presents thawing turkeys and making sure
we still have that one ugly Christmas
sweater for the party in a couple weeks
and then all of a sudden you just blink
and it's January and we feel behind on
everything that doesn't have to be the
way you start off the new year make
plans now to start the New Year Strong
by joining us for Building Wealth live
right here in Nashville Tennessee on
January the 12th we're also headed to
Indianapolis Austin Salt Lake City and
Anaheim with dates into the spring and
this is a one night event that will help
you kick off 2023 feeling confident
about your finances even in this crazy
economy
so join Dave Ramsey myself Rachel Cruz
Ken Coleman Dr John deloney as we walk
you through a simple but proven plan to
pay off debt and build wealth it is
possible and passes for this start at
just 39 bucks but seats are limited for
this event so head to
ramseysolutions.com events to reserve
your seat for our Building Wealth live
in Nashville today it will sell out
don't miss it your future self will
thank you for it that's
ramseysolutions.com
events I'm George Campbell joined by
Christina Ellis this hour this is the
Ramsey show it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jessica joins us up next in Miami
Jessica welcome to the show
hi George hi Christina thank you for
having me absolutely how can we help
today
okay so I'm gonna try to make this brief
um so in 2020 I got furloughed and
eventually I left my job in January of
2021 and my 401k just kind of sat in my
retirement account that that whole time
um up until about last month actually I
had that transferred over into a
traditional IRA account with my bank
with my bank that I use and so my
husband and I um recently got very
serious about putting a hard debt and we
are on baby step number two we've paid
everything off with the exception of One
credit card that we will pay off by the
end of this month and that will leave us
with just our student loan debt um so I
have about 29 000 in student loan debt
and my husband has about 8 000 now going
back to that retirement account I have
about thirty two thousand dollars just
sitting um like I said in that in that
traditional IRA account it hadn't been
any transactions I initially I I wanted
to
um use that as my retirement investment
account but before I do that I just
wanted to see if it would make sense to
use that to go ahead and pay off my
balance and just leave my husband's
eight thousand dollars student loan that
I am so glad you called Jessica to talk
you off of the ledge of robbing your
retirement and your future with all
kinds of penalties and interest
so glad I called you then no we we never
recommend
robbing your retirement unless you're
facing a bankruptcy or some kind of
insane situation but you guys got this
you can use your future income to pay
this down how long is it going to take
to pay off the rest
so we pay about two thousand dollars a
month so there's about what what is that
uh 29 and eight thirty about 38 000 in
there so about about 18 19 months maybe
okay if we can do that 2000 every month
yeah and that'll put you a total
timeline of what for your whole debt
free Journey
uh about a year and a half Oh you mean
total um so we've been doing it about
it's going to be about two years
probably that's spot on that's exactly
the average amount of time it takes if
your gazelle intense you're following
this stuff 18 to 24 months is The Sweet
Spot to pay off your debt and so uh you
guys have got this I know you're you're
just now really excited and you're like
what else can accelerate this oh there's
a pile of money over here right
you're right keep that excitement though
keep that excitement I love the
intensity I mean that's where we want
you we want you to have that gazelle
intensity but you know just if there's
anything you're gonna do to throw more
fuel on the fire you know think of
things that are you know gonna be extra
income maybe there's somewhere else you
can cut back but definitely don't Rob
your retirement
okay that makes total sense thank you
guys so much yeah and if you need more
encouragement go pop those numbers in
whatever's in your IRA put it into our
investing calculator ramsaysolutions.com
and then look 20 years out look what
that money turned into
and so robbing that down to zero and
instead of letting compound growth do
its work uh on top of the fact that if
you withdrew that money you're going to
have penalties it's going to be taxed it
is never never worth it to take that
kind of hit well because the ultimate
goal where we want to true you truly see
you in 10 years we want you to be baby
step millionaires you know in 10 to 15
years so it's like that that Ira it's a
huge part of you getting to that real
next level like we want you to be
ultimately successful in the long term
and so we don't want you to take any
short-term you know kind of get out of
jail free cards that could actually hurt
that long-term trajectory so you're
gonna get there we're excited for you
and I hope that whenever you know you're
done in a year and a half we see you
right there on that stage screaming out
that you're debt free yes and if anyone
out there is thinking about cashing out
of their 401K their IRAs number one
because they're scared of the market
number two because they want to pay off
some debt please let me talk you off the
ledge right now do not do that and if
you're not working with an investment
professional like a smart investor Pro
that we have at ramseysolutions.com you
need to work with one because they're so
good at talking off the ledge showing
you long-term track records being The
Voice of Truth in a world that's kind of
gone mad and we feel like
all the anxiety I'm seeing my account go
down I need to cash out cash out and
inflation and all the different things I
think people are feeling a lot of fear
and a lot of anxiety so just keeping
that level-headedness is key especially
in the season going into the holidays
seeing the market down all these things
added up together stay the course yeah
it can produce some some not great
decisions so yeah glad you talked people
off the ledge George yeah that's what
I'm here for Jake joins us up next in
Madison Wisconsin Jake welcome to the
show
foreign
hey guys how are you today doing great
what's going on with you
good
um so I am a CPA out of Madison
Wisconsin
um and I have a girlfriend who's also
works in uh Madison Wisconsin area
and we're both 25 and she currently
rents and I currently live at home with
my parents
um I've accumulated quite a bit of money
um a little over a hundred grand I would
say and
she has about 35
000 in debt total
um
and that might play into the
conversation later but my main question
is she has a we're looking to move in
together right and she has a lease
that's up in about a month
and I'm I guess I'm on the fence whether
I want to take the leap and start paying
rent
and make that Split Decision in the next
month to move in and have those expenses
or hold off and then potentially buy a
house or something like that in the next
year
um how serious is this girlfriend
um we've been dating for about a year
um we've known each other for a couple
years now
what's holding holding you from asking
her to marry you
um
I I guess nothing nothing much
um
I guess we would we're almost at that
level
I think when we're starting to talk big
decisions like moving in together and
finances and combining finances I mean
that's such an important conversation to
have because those are really huge
commitments and money fights and money
problems are one of the number one
reasons relationships don't work out and
when you move in together you were just
it's a recipe for disaster when it comes
to finances because we haven't combined
finances and now she's contributing
towards you paying down the mortgage but
she has no real uh buy-in into this and
so I've only seen it gone poorly and so
I would I would recommend you to not
have her move in whether you rent or buy
until you guys are married and if you're
ready to buy a house regardless of the
relationship status that's okay if you
want to do that as long as you're debt
free with an emergency fund and the
payment's going to be no more than a 25
of your take-home pay on a 15-year fixed
are you at that point
um I would I would say are you just
talking about buying a house in general
yeah and at that level of
I I could definitely buy a house right
now if I wanted to yes okay
well I would still tread slowly because
as Dave likes to say as soon as you're
married she wants a different house and
so you know if this is a serious
relationship I might put pause in the
home buying process and say hey is this
going to be something I I really pursue
towards engagement towards marriage and
then we're going to make that decision
together and if you keep stacking cash
in the meantime there's nothing wrong
with that so I appreciate the call man
that's it you're at a Crossroads of some
really big decisions and I hope you do
it with a lot of patience and not a lot
of impulse yeah and maybe I mean the
lease is up in a month maybe figure out
a solution you know maybe she can rent
month month to month for a while because
whenever we have those time pressures it
can lead us to you know make hasty
decisions that often aren't the best
choice or here's a wild solution just
sign a new lease life goes on it's
amazing how that works appreciate the
call more of the Ramsey Show we'll be
back with you real soon
[Music]
foreign
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the ponds
Moving and Storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host Christina Ellis
joined by my co-host George Campbell
give us a call Triple eight eight two
five five two two five first up we've
got Brian calling from Greenville South
Carolina hey Brian welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
thanks for calling how can we help
um so I'm working through baby steps
um four five and six I'm contributing
like 21 to my 401k
but I want to know if I should back that
down and tackle the house
well how much do you have left on the
house
um I just bought it two years ago I owe
192.
what made you decide to go with 21
that's very specific
um so I put in the 15 percent
you know that Dave recommends my company
matches
four percent and then every year they
automatically bump up my contribution uh
one percent so
I guess I'm contributing 17 myself and
then my company matches four percent oh
okay can you can you stop the auto
automatic upgrade in your 401k there
yeah I can okay
yeah I'd bump that back down to 15 until
the house is paid off and then you can
go Hog Wild
so should I back mine down to 11 and let
my I mean you you'd go to 15 of your
income regardless of what's happening
with the match
okay and do you have kids
I have one okay are you saving for
college
uh yeah I started a uh 529 Forum a year
ago awesome great well you're doing
awesome I mean you're pretty close to
being right on plan just with that
little two percent change I mean you're
right on on track and I love your
motivation to pay off the house I love
that you're getting so fired up what's
your timeline to pay it off
yeah that's I got a plan for about eight
years oh I think you can do better than
that what's your income
um my base salary is 60 000 but with
overtime I do close to
70 72. that's awesome and you've got
some margin to put on the house once you
get that two percent back how much are
we talking towards the extra towards the
mortgage
I do minimum a hundred dollars a month
but I get yearly bonuses through work
that you know a few thousand dollars
um I have a couple side hustles and any
extra money kind of goes towards that I
love it and your income is going to go
up over the next eight years
yeah hopefully anyway yeah you're a
sharp dude and so that's going to speed
up this uh payoff so absolutely I'd bump
your contribution down to 15 keep saving
for college and then any extra margin
you can throw put that onto the mortgage
way to go yeah way to go you're you're
definitely you know in a really good
spot and I love that you're just walking
out the example of how to do the baby
steps well and I also love the match
that's just such a great love a match
around we love a great match all right
next up we have Luke calling from
Indianapolis Indiana hey Luke welcome to
the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call hey
thanks for calling how can we help
um so I feel like my um my budget like
my margins each month um I'm not quite
achieving any of my goals um I'm trying
to be as aggressive with
as I can with my uh student loan
repayments but I also have a couple
other things I'm saving for
um my truck has not been super
dependable so I'm saving to replace that
and then I'm also getting married
um next year so I'm kind of saving for
those expenses and moving out and stuff
and so I'm looking at my account each
month and I'm not really getting
anywhere because I feel like I'm
spreading it all too thin so maybe you
guys could help me prioritize
yeah well congrats on getting engaged
that's exciting you got some cool things
on the horizon so how much debt do you
have
uh right now I have about 19 000 Poland
student loans all right and what's your
income
uh about 50 000. all right and when
you're you're doing your monthly budget
do you think it's a spending problem is
it because you're saving toward the car
and the wedding where do you think the
problem lies
is it an income
it could mean an income problem I'm not
spending anything and part of it could
be maybe it's maybe it's not necessary
to save as much as I think like for the
car and for the wedding but
um like I'm saving pretty much 50 of my
income goes towards my debt so I live
off of the rest and you know I'm saving
about I don't know four or five hundred
dollars a month
and I guess I'm just not sure should I
make less aggressive payments on my debt
and save just kind of for this season or
how is this truck on its last leg
you said you're trying to replace your
car
it's it's hard to say it's I've had to
take it to the shop pretty much every
month nothing major but 150 here 300
here and that's also kind of slowing
down by my saving what do you do for a
living
I'm a teacher a teacher okay and are you
doing any sort of side hustle or
anything to make additional income
um I'm not the primary reason is um I
teach band and so I have a lot of after
school commitments
um a lot of extracurricular activities
um so I don't exactly have a normal
teacher schedule yeah no man can get
pretty intense what about off seasons do
you have you know Seasons where you're
not you know having after school hours
with the band
yeah my summers are definitely
um available I've I've worked over the
summers in the past and been able to
make you know three or four thousand
dollars in in a month or two like June
and July yeah I think I mean right now I
love that you're taking 50 of your
income and throwing it towards the debt
I think right now it's just that season
where it's a challenge you gotta be
gazelle intense you got to kind of go
through the slog this is the not fun
part of it but you know it's gonna get
you to a spot where once that nineteen
thousand dollars is out of your life
once that debt is gone that money is
going to be able to really go towards
savings and you're going to see a lot of
progress I know it's frustrating right
now because you don't see that savings
progress you're going oh man
um but it's gonna it's gonna get there I
think it's just kind of one of those
Seasons where you got to stay the course
and keep pushing through do you know how
much you are having to pay for this
wedding have you guys talked about with
the families who's paying what do you
have a clear number
yeah so
um
the family is able to contribute pretty
much everything for the wedding
um I'm paying for the honeymoon and then
I'm also wanting to save some money just
for like
the first month right and you know the
deposit and I have no furniture so I
live at home right now so I mean I'll be
moving out for the first time so I've
also been saving a little bit for that
awesome well it sounds like you're doing
all the right things I'd get a clear
number of what I'm gonna need for all
those wedding expenses if that's four
thousand dollars for honeymoon plus plus
then we backtrack that out and go all
right every month I need to save 400 to
have forty eight hundred dollars 12
months from that one so you start to do
that kind of math and that gives you
your goal and if that means I need a
side hustle then go get you a side
hustle for a season yeah and I think
that's just important to remember that
it is for a season you know you're
coming up on that marriage and it's
gonna feel so good to do it debt free
and to be really seeing that traction
with your wife as you're able to throw
that money into savings we'll be right
back give us a call Triple A
825-5225 this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
if you've gone through FPU chances are
it's because someone in your life lit a
fire under you Mom and Dad gave it to
you as a gift your pastor offered it at
your church or that one friend wouldn't
stop talking about it so you finally
took the class started working the baby
steps and now everything's different
your entire future changed now you can
light a fire under someone else you can
give someone you care about Financial
Peace University and share the same hope
you've discovered with money and with
Christmas coming this is the perfect
time to do it and when you give FPU as a
gift they get more than just a course
they'll also get the premium version of
every dollar so you that they can start
living on a budget plus they can even
join in on group calls with our
financial coaches which I've been on
those calls these are amazing this
Christmas give the people you care about
a gift that actually matters and that's
hope that's freedom to buy FPU as a gift
go to ramseysolutions Dot com slash give
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com give FPU
George see we get some interesting
messages on Instagram some of them are a
little wild and some of them were
actually pretty eye-opening and you got
one and our fans like to send me this
stuff because I know that I know what
Riles me up Christina and Tosh sent me
this uh she got an email from her credit
union in California and it's a new
product from the credit union that's
called The Making Memories loan oh gosh
so let me read you their their marketing
copy here they have like beautiful
photos of like graduations and weddings
and families having a great time and it
says you can focus on enjoying the
occasion Altura is there to help with
the expense oh what a blessing it goes
on to say whether it's a wedding family
reunion graduation party or any other
type of Celebration Altura can help make
the making with the making memories loan
it's quick and simple great low rates no
collateral needed up to 30 grand with
just your signature oh what a gift what
is this from the credit union that has a
whole bunch of strings attached we'll
put you in debt for years it's lovely
and pretty and light and Airy what gets
me is this like they're gonna pull at
our our emotional heartstrings to go
like do what's right for your family
even if you're broke so that you can
make a memory
kind of gross actually extra gross you
know it's funny I was listening to the
radio the other day and I heard a
commercial for a cash advance company
and the language around it was similar
it was really kind of disgusting they
were like you can take control of your
finances you can be the person in your
family you're struggling with bills
you're struggling to do things if you
take out this loan you're in control 200
interest right yeah like of all
companies to be promising that you are
not the company well I expect you I
expect that from a Payday lender and
cash advance folks I don't expect it
from your local credit union be better
be better be better Unforgettable
moments
the flowery pretty language It's just
sad because you know somebody's falling
for that you know the reason they're
doing it is because for someone that
worked yes
the memory comes with payments every
month with interest and now you get to
relive that memory every month when you
send that credit union your payment oh
angrily going well I guess there goes
that vacation yeah that's painful ugh
all right let's go to the phones up next
we have Paul calling from Seattle
Washington hey Paul welcome to the show
hello hello to the Dave Ramsey team uh
really glad uh for you for taking my
call I appreciate it yeah thanks for
calling how can we help
yeah I have uh kind of a happy problem
and probably know what uh what you're
going to say but uh but here's where I'm
at uh recently I was very fortunate to
land a job that pays significantly
higher than what I was making uh
previously and with a different pay
structure and I have a mortgage and with
the added income I'm wondering how I
should think about uh putting towards my
mortgage versus adding more towards my
retirement
um yeah that's that's my question we'll
send it congrats on the pay bump that's
great so what is your income now
yeah right now it's it's an all-cash uh
income uh about 765
000 a year wow
765
000 a year what do you do for a living
I'm a software engineer in Seattle all
right I could probably guess who it's
for that's a very impressive man good
for you you must be a very good engineer
I don't know about that but yeah I
consider myself lucky to have landed the
job I love it okay so what is your
mortgage what's left on it
uh it's a 1.3 million is left of my
mortgage uh it's uh it's a 2.6 interest
rate I pay about 6500 per month and to
get to get the lowest interest rate I
opted for a seven year arm which was
offering at that point uh the lowest
interest rate oh so there are six years
left on the ERM and that could change
that is correct okay do you think you
could pay it off in six years
I think so uh six years it might be
tight but uh I think I should be I was
uh with the new income I should be able
to yeah because that's uh doing the math
here that's throwing 216 Grand of your
765 obviously high taxes there so I
don't know what you're taking home out
of that 765 probably closer to 350.
yeah three 380 390 is what I take home
okay yeah I think that's doable do you
think you could throw 200 Grand a year
at this thing
um I I think so yeah I'm just wondering
should I should I use some of that
towards my I'm already probably matching
out my 401K Roth IRA Mega back door off
HFA FSA uh that's amazing and also I can
do more towards like with the
traditional brokerage account so should
I do a little bit of that or should I
just go to go towards my mortgage I
would cap it at 15 and so whatever gets
you there from that you know obviously
that's a giant number from 765 and you
take 15 of that that's 114 Grand and so
if you've already maxed out everything
and there's still money left over to get
to that 15 you can throw that Chunk in a
taxable brokerage account to kind of
finish it out
I see do you have any kids
uh yeah I have a one-year-old okay have
you started a 529
yes I have okay great you're you're just
a rock star I'm just so excited for you
I'm like this guy I mean are you already
a millionaire
uh I don't know my house is probably at
about two two million so adding all of
that up and my three some of some of the
stocks I have from my previous job
probably close to yeah I'd say so wow
could you cash out of those stocks at
this point
uh I can I will have to pay a lot of
capital gains though because I did have
quite a lot of games on those stocks
this may be a silly question but I just
want to ask it just in case you don't
have any other debt do you
uh no no dad I love it yeah I mean you
can I would work with the tax Pro to
look at the kind of tax structures and
what you would owe if you did certain
things but it may be really cool to cash
out of some of those stocks maybe over a
period of time so that you don't have as
much of a tax burden and pay off the
house so that's so cool that's amazing
there's one more thing uh the uh about
my situation so I I'm an immigrant in
this country I'm on a work visa so just
thinking about like a worst case
situation so uh if I lose my job then
I'm not able to get another job I might
have to leave the country does that
change your answer at all in terms of
paying off mortgage or versus putting
toward uh towards the retirement no it
doesn't because if you were if you had
to leave the country for some reason I
would sell the property leaving you with
a giant chunk of money and all the money
you're putting into that mortgage is now
built in to the sale of the home you're
going to get it all back in equity
I see okay yeah you're doing great this
is this is amazing you're going to be
able to leave quite the Legacy to your
child and build quite the nest egg it's
you're you're killing it I had to almost
blink for a second when he said his
income I thought he said 75 000 and then
I was like wait a minute well those are
those Seattle software Engineers
Christina they make buku bucks and of
course in Seattle it's very expensive
there's high taxes and so it's kind of
like a Silicon Valley level situation
but man I'll take 765 thousand dollars
even with high taxes that's impressive
great way to build some wealth I love
the motivation we've had so many people
call today about wanting to pay off
their house and getting excited about
paying off their house but I think it's
still important to kind of have that
discussion of how important it is to
still save for retirement of course you
know the last caller he's being
aggressive with retirement still but
there's been some calls where people are
tempted to stop retirement investing
just to pay off the house what would you
say to those people who are kind of
feeling that pull to stop investing well
I think we have to have a long-term
mindset and think about out I want to be
able to retire in 20 years and not have
my kids have to cover the bill I want my
kids and I have the burden of student
loans so let me make sure I invest 15 my
kids college is taken care of and the
house will get paid for and if it slows
it down that's okay you gotta think long
term yes we love the motivation we love
how inspired you are but we we're in it
for the long game we're trying to
there's more to life than just paying
off the house right we want you to be
baby step Millionaires and that means
focusing on all areas following the
Steps step by step we'll be right back
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Christina Ellis joined today by my
co-host George camel we're taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five next up we have John
calling from Los Angeles California hey
John welcome to the show
hi
how can we help
I had an insurance question life
insurance
um I'm 70 years old and I have a term
life insurance policy that's good until
um 2025
and it's costing me about 200 a month
and
my
financial advisor said that I should get
a whole life insurance
now while I'm still 70 instead of
waiting until I'm a couple years older
and it's gonna I I've already
applied for it and I can get it but it's
going to be like 1165 dollars a month I
was just wondering
if it would be better to hold off let my
other term life run out and then try to
get another term life or to try to get a
whole life did your agent quote you for
another term life or did he just offer
you whole life
they just offered me whole life can I
tell you what's actually going on here
John
pardon me can I tell you what's actually
happening here
yeah your financial advisor is just a
whole life salesman and the reason he's
pushing whole life is because he's
making a giant spread on that premium
and he's going to make very little
comparatively on a term life policy
yeah the fact that he didn't even offer
you or quote you the term life is a
pretty big red flag
so tell us a little bit more about your
financial situation
um do you have any debt
um I have a house payment
that's the only thing what's in
retirement
um I have social security and a
retirement from the IBEW okay what's
that amount to
it's not a lot it's only about 3 800 a
month okay
so the idea with term life is that by
the time it's over you're self-insured
and you'd be able to cover any costs
um so if you don't have that ability to
cover those costs I would still steer
you to another term life policy even
though it's going to be expensive but it
still won't be nearly as expensive as
that whole life policy
right that's what I was thinking I I'm
just
he's trying to tell and the whole life
that they're talking about is 300 000
and the term that I have now is 500 000.
yeah it's because whole life sucks and
it's super expensive and uh as an
example a 250 000 policy might cost you
260 a month on your premiums with whole
life
but with a term life policy might cost
you 13 bucks a month so it's
astronomically cheaper uh for the same
amount of coverage and the money you
save you can invest the difference if
you've got it
and whole life is terrible because it
tries to do two things at once it tries
to be an investment vehicle and an
insurance vehicle and it ends up not
being great at either one so if I'm you
honestly in your shoes I'm firing the
financial advisor and saying hey it's
been great working with you uh sayonara
and you can go connect with a better
financial advisor called smartvestor pro
at ramsaysolutions.com who isn't going
to steer you towards these crappy Whole
Life policies so wishing you the best
John with these decisions but run far
away from this yeah that's oh it just
breaks my heart when financial advisors
who you go to because you trusts them
with your biggest life decisions and
your biggest money decisions steer you
to these crappy products also they can
get a bigger cut that's just sad it
feels like such a cash grab but thank
you for calling I'm glad you know you
did have that gut check that made you go
this just doesn't feel right thank you
for that John hopefully we talked him
off the ledge yeah up next we have Julie
calling from Chattanooga Tennessee hey
Julie welcome to the show
hi hey so um
I'm gonna jump right in so I'm working
two full-time jobs right now
um and physically just kind of feel like
I'm killing myself
um so I'm wondering does it make sense
to pay for a certification
um and go through some training that
would allow me to take an online job
even though I'm you know skill driven in
debt and all of those things well how
much debt do you have
about sixty thousand okay and what what
kind of work are you doing right now
with these two full-time jobs
though I am a teacher and then I work in
a factory at night wow you are hustling
those are not easy jobs
no no they're not no wonder you feel
tired what's your total income from
those jobs
uh my total income is about 60 000 with
those two
so if you were to go back to school what
would you want to study
well um I have a degree already in
Business Administration but I was
thinking if I go more for a
certification not in a college either
something in accounting that would allow
me to do that or
um something in web development maybe
back in web development
I mean that's definitely a possibility I
mean have you looked into jobs that you
could get right now without an extra
certification that are outside of
teaching
well the teaching job is the one that I
really want to hold on to it doesn't pay
much of anything but it's kind of what
makes me human so I want to hold that
hey we need more people like you in the
world unless the teachers as a mother I
am very concerned about the education
system so thank you for what you do
well thank you so this extra job are you
looking at another full-time job that's
basically online
yeah maybe full time I think part time I
could probably do but it would slow down
any process of getting rid of debt for
sure yeah have you looked at the price
of the certification programs
not really no I've looked just a little
bit here and there
um but it would take a lot of research
to figure out you know get past just all
the advertisements to get to what's real
yeah well I know that there are some
pretty affordable ones right now and
some are even free I know that a lot of
companies like I believe Google's got a
really cool program right now where
they'll train people for jobs that
they're that they have in demand and
they'll train people for free so really
I mean with a business administration
degree I mean there's a lot of
possibility right now to look into
potentially a very low cost or free
program that could yield a pretty cool
job yeah and I'm going to give to Julie
Ken Coleman's get clear career
assessment to help you figure out
exactly what the path is because you
mentioned a few options there and I want
you to not just do the one that pays the
most but do the one that you're also
passionate about and I think you can
make great money doing the thing that
you love and that's what our friend Ken
teaches every day so we're going to give
you that it'll take you about 20 minutes
to go through but that will help steer
you towards the right direction uh what
kind of debt is this the 60k
so it's a pretty even three-way split
with student loan a car and then just
credit card you know junk debt okay have
you cut up the cards
no but I don't use them then cut them up
that's a great way to never be able to
use them uh it can become a crutch when
you fall on Hard Times you go well at
least the credit card companies are
there for me except they're not because
they're there at 22 interest keeping you
in debt longer and longer so cut those
up uh would you consider selling the car
is it worth more than you owe
um no it's not so I actually just bought
out my sister's Leaf which was the
cheapest way to get a car because our
other car um didn't have air
conditioning we'd fixed it several times
and then it goes back out we were just
kind of draining money
um so I'm not sure that there's really a
better option for me to go for right now
so what's left on the car loan
we just did that so it's right at 20.
okay when you say we who was involved
here
my husband okay is his income factored
into this
no it's not so what is is his income not
helping pay down this debt
we're not organized
um and so we still feel like we're
living paycheck to paycheck pinching the
pennies
um yeah that's that's the real crisis
here Julie I'm gonna be honest I'm going
to put you guys uh through Financial
Peace University on us if you're willing
to do it is he on board or is he kind of
skeptical towards this whole thing and
going well that's your dad not mine
we share the finances but I'm really the
one who manages it and so I think it's
he doesn't feel all the stress that I do
because it's easier for him not to look
at it as intently if you're carrying the
brunt of all of the stress and burden
and two full-time jobs and he's like
well she manages the money
I guess oh Julie Julie Julie all right
we're gonna gift it to you I hope that
you guys go through it have a serious
conversation and go I'm not okay I'm
scared I'm tired I'm burnt out I need
you on board in this marriage and if
he's not willing to do that we got
bigger issues and counseling needs to
get involved here yeah I'm so sorry
Julie that's tough and y'all are just
running so fast right now taking the
time to you know slow down get educated
get on a budget that alone is probably
going to save you all so much so hang on
the line we'll get you the get clear
assessment and Financial Peace
University we're cheering you on this is
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the day that the Lord has made
let us rejoice and be glad in it Psalms
118 24 give every day the chance to
become the most beautiful day of your
life Mark Twain
that's beautiful beautiful reminders
there yeah sometimes you just need that
little reminder all right let's go back
to the phones first we have Lewis
calling from Miami Florida hey Lewis
welcome to the show
hi guys thank you for having me hey
thanks for being here how can we help
well I'm in a financial crisis and and
actually
um I'm anxious and I'm scared uh we sold
our home uh eight months ago and we had
proceeds of about seventy thousand
dollars
but because our debt to ratio is upside
down we've been finding ourselves
dipping off of that money
and paying bills and we're down to 37
000 to buy a home and we're scared
because we're still upside down in our
debt
well tell us about this debt how much
debt do you have
well together with the two vehicles that
I have I have about seventy six thousand
dollars in debt
just all vehicles
no that's just uh the 33 000 is credit
cards and small loans and the rest is
for the two cars
but 76 is the total
correct okay what was your household
income
household income is about a hundred and
fifteen thousand okay
uh I mean I'm looking at the numbers
here it gives me a lot of Hope
but I think part of it is have you
continued using the credit cards
well it's okay but starting today I
think we need to cut them up because
it's a crutch that's causing you to go
further into debt and on top of that
you're depleting the money so you're
using the credit cards but you also said
you're dipping into the proceeds from
the home sale
that's correct and is that going to just
cover the bills or do is there a
spending habit issues as well
well it's mostly covering the bills from
spending on credit cards and and small
loans things like that
now what are the cars worth
because I was actually coincidentally I
I went in a praise one of the cars today
and they're actually giving more than
what I owe on the vehicle this is a
great situation if I'm in your shoes and
you're feeling that level of anxiety
like you can't crawl out of this thing I
would sell the cars and purchase
something a a very reasonable affordable
used car with cash with the savings that
you have
and with the proceeds from the you know
the profits from the car sales
okay because that would leave you with
how much debt if you got rid of all the
car loans you just had the credit cards
and personal loans that leaves you with
33k
that's correct and frees up the payments
that you were making on those car loans
now making a hundred fifteen thousand
with more margin how quickly could you
pay off thirty three thousand
right makes sense that gives me that you
feel that energy that we just created
there the momentum
yes you did and so I think that is your
next step but beyond that we have to
change our Behavior because selling the
cars is a great shortcut it's like a
life hack right but we have not touched
the behavior of what caused us to spend
and so part of that is the debt payments
for sure but part of it is we've got to
get on a budget we are not eating out we
are scared to our we have got to get out
of debt if it's the last thing we do
and I think that's part of the reason
you've called today I can hear it in
your voice I mean it sounds like you've
had that I've had it moment it may have
just recently happened but it seems like
it's happened is that correct oh no that
is definitely correct uh uh I've not
only had it but I'm almost to the scared
point
because this is the money that we had to
buy our home we're renting now waiting
to find our home but the money's
depleting pretty quickly well that's
when a lot of times real life change
happens when people hit that spot where
they're like we cannot live life like
this anymore it is time to change that's
when Real Change happens so I know today
is scary and I know that you feel that
palpitation in your in your chest and it
feels nerve-wracking but I I know it's
hard to hear this but that's a good
thing because today is the day that
everything's going to change today's
going to be the day that you look back
on when you're on that debt-free stage
and you say that's the day that
everything changed that's the day I made
a decision I stopped spending on credit
cards I changed my mindset I got an ftu
and I was all in and Louis I don't want
to be the bearer of bad news here but
you're not ready to be a homeowner right
now and so I know you see this pile of
cash and go well that's for the home
right now it's to pay off the debt
because that home is going to own you if
you jump into it right now
and so here's if I'm in your shoes and
you want to follow the baby steps you
want to be gazelle intense here's what
you're doing you're selling both cars
and hopefully the profits from that can
get you used cars if you need to dip
into some of that savings to make it
happen that's okay but the rest of that
money you might have 33 000 left in
savings for 34 000 and you can clean up
the rest of that debt
this week
right think about that you're in a
position where by the end of the week
you could be completely debt free with
no payments and about a thousand bucks
in the bank and yes it feels like well
we're moving backwards no my friend you
are moving forwards because you are not
paying interest you don't owe anyone
anything and now all of that hundred
fifteen thousand can help you build back
up your fully funded emergency fund
which means you're never going back into
debt again and then we can start saving
back up for the house so it may be three
years before you're ready to jump into a
house which I know is frustrating but
man you're going to be in a different
place financially by the end of the week
if you follow this stuff Louis how does
that feel that makes a lot of sense
well I want to equip you I know we can't
do it all on a radio call I'm gonna gift
you one year of Financial Peace
University I want you to watch those
videos with your family all nine lessons
get fired up use the every dollar
budgeting tool to make a plan for every
single dollar coming in and man please
call us back when you're debt free I
love we always love the where are they
now stories Christina we never get to
hear it and I can feel the fire that
Lewis has got and we want to keep that
going so hang on the line Austin's gonna
pick up we'll gift you one year of
financial peace and every dollar premium
yes I'm excited to hear that success
story all right we got time for one more
call we've got Hannah calling from
Peoria Illinois hey Hannah welcome to
the show
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call yeah um I just had a quick question
about where to look for scholarships
um I have the opportunity to start a
bachelor's program in January with my
employer paying pretty much all of the
tuition
um it covers things like books or fees
or anything like that
okay that's great that's amazing that
you got your employer to cover that
that's fantastic and you can still make
money while going to school so that's
fantastic yes and I love a good
scholarship conversation one of my
favorite databases to look at is
scholarship owl and they're great
because basically a scholarship database
it goes through all the millions of
scholarships out there and it takes
information about you and helps match
you with scholarships that specifically
fit you so that's where I would start is
looking at databases I'd also look at
the school that you're going to so
that's awesome there okay employer is
you know covering tuition but see if the
school has any scholarships have you
checked that yet
uh not yet I just got the um
the news that I was going to be that I
got accepted as one of the 55 that
they're offering this to
um and so I got that call earlier this
week well congratulations that's amazing
and I love that your first go-to is to
immediately start thinking through how
can I pay for the rest of this without
debt that your first thought is you know
what scholarship can I find how can I
hustle how can I figure this out so
that's outstanding yes do you know is
there this is actually my
yeah keep going
uh this is actually going to be my
second bachelor's and I did the first
one with about 90 000 in uh student
loans but I'm still working on trying to
pay off so I do not definitely do not
want to be going back into any more
loans
yes and amen well you just said debt is
off the table because I know what that's
like never again yeah oh that is so cool
to hear Hannah well we're cheering you
on and it's amazing what happens
Christina when you just decide you
pre-decide that debt is not an option
all of a sudden you get real creative
and it causes you to be patient and do
your research and be intentional and
look for the scholarships and work and
all of these things combined cause you
to have that success to cause you to go
to college debt free absolutely taking
it off the table is just a game changer
and I will say with scholarships be
willing to be patient on the front end
and do the research I think people want
to get on Google in about 30 minutes and
find a list of 100 perfect scholarships
that just apply to them but it can take
some time like you gotta do the work on
the front end so that you're really
applying for the scholarships that fit
you best but I'm excited for you that
it's amazing that you're going to go to
nursing school debt free I love it so
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books if you like the show please
consider subscribing leaving a review
and sharing it with a friend big thanks
to all the guys in the booth for running
the show to my co-host George Campbell
and to you America thanks for listening
we'll be back soon this is the Ramsay
show
have a good day Brandt want to see the
latest Ramsay show videos going viral
check out your favorite moments from the
Ramsay show on YouTube go watch And
subscribe to the Ramsay show channel on
YouTube
[Music]